[Music]
sometime the nekkid League can get more
detail in a motor-driven clip I'm fly
him out as head master barber from
Software Inc k-8 the fade King I'm here
to walk you through twelve phase and
hairstyles from textures to tune this is
Fahim Alexander let's go
so the first one we guy has the dirt
feed this is a taper style cut with a
comb-over and a part we taper the bottom
you know either a1 to a2 to a3 dingo
only up to the point even though
different companies have different sizes
there's a general standard for clipper
guide numbers generally the clipper
guard number represents the number of
1/8 inches of hair left on the head
lower number clipper guards leave less
hair on the head a higher number clipper
guards be more hair on the head the
number 1 guard leaves 1/8 length of the
hair on the head the number 2 guard
leaves 1/4 limp the number 3 guard these
3/8 list the number 4 guard bees 1 half
its length of the hair on the head did
you notice a difference between the
taper anything a tape restorer set short
hair wears or thin starts at skin here
we have the skin drop feed one of my
favorites is real smooth and easy to do
start off skinning it fall you want to
go from a 0 to a 1 to a 2 and feed it
all the way up to your pump so in this
next photo we got here is the taper fade
with long hair this fade right here is
one of my favorite fades from the 81.5
guard trim off a little off the top
I think every barbershop can be a safe
place for women check this cut out that
I'm gonna do it on my friend Rea
oh yeah I love the style of every people
- thank you I'm actually excited you'll
be the first person to cut my hair that
isn't me in five years
oh wow so what do you like what do you
what I usually do like a - up to about
here and then maybe a three going out
open another nice if you wanna you want
to get that Fame going back here looks
fun
that'd be perfect yeah come so normally
when clients come into the barbershop
and they want this to style right here I
always have a comb or handy and I'm
gonna using my 357 clipper from caliber
so about Cora is my best but then we're
just going somewhere here sniffing easy
can you call me back there go up a
little bit more this is I love this step
already
so tell me something do you wear any
like desires or anything back here we
just wait natural well I've done just
like a couple steps here but I really
like couple parts yeah would you like to
see that again yeah why not okay great
I've got a tape we're down a little bit
more it's like get a little bit onto the
surface you have all types of mazes back
here they take what sometimes right this
cool don't sleep you want to like this
though we took it yeah I don't know
where you're finding all these gray
hairs I'll put some in my pots out
let's look fantastic it's just soft
enough it's not too hard of an edge it's
got really great flow I can play with it
it's gonna blend really nicely when it's
growing out so area what do you think
very happy love it love it
alright so here we got our fourth feet
one of the most common Custis wore today
and one and a half the size cut into a
box of texture some people that sported
this haircut in the eighties kids play
salt and pepper cameo ever be Rock him
and Big Daddy Kane Public Enemy and EPMD
and my guy from my city Will Smith Fresh
Prince of Bel Air
your bottle would tell you he will have
the keys to success of keeping you to
shape you know I like a little bit of
spritz a holding spray a blow dryer back
in the day you know you're the mare in
the bathroom you know you Pat me down to
make that square shape every other week
to keep it fresh you should buzz your
size so number five we got the temple
taper fade with the kinky hair that's
most common today with the brothers with
the beard you could start from his skin
fade and the blend down into your beard
so make it too dark so your beard is
like a three it could grow a little bit
natural to keep this haircut right right
here you want to use your favorite
sponge or your favorite curly racquet
so what this down I mean you can shampoo
it every night to be honest with you if
you like but you know you need these
steps number one you know you want to
get your favorite shampoo and
conditioner number two you know you want
to put your favorite pomade in the hair
maybe use a blow dryer dry it your
favorite curly racket or your sponge so
number six we got the hi world I'm gonna
cut my boy Jesse he wants to sport that
no fade trim on time come on in Jesse
you don't know right Victor Cruz will
you'd only go to the barbershop like
what the waxwork I used to say give me a
low fade or a high Brooke just basically
just gonna taper and I get a tape at our
behind that's the new one to me the hi
Brooke what are they called behind
Brooke was ask somebody with Brooklyn
yeah so you know a lot of cats instead
of getting a full-on fade they just want
to get the Brooklyn which is just taper
the edges a little bit you know I want
my own tapered I usually want to get a
higher taper so I'll call it - hi Brooke
this is some different terminology right
anywhere else they just say give me a
temple thing that's it so to make this
ha Brooke I want to brush it out where
I'm going to do most of my work out so I
got my outline of twos here and I'm just
gonna start to make a small thing
maybe booties all day long down the feel
of it he just called temple things those
are the cons here but the hi Brooke is
funny that's different to me what I got
now it's just like 50 Matt in caliber
great the tapering ball tapering and
trimming critique you the top then I
have the new and this court is master
for detail work of designs I use this
for my trimming to make my boxes and my
afros then we got the 357 caliber it's
all around clipper that I can use all
day so Jessie I think I did the Brooklyn
man it's my first time doing it I think
I know you tell me okay did I tell you
man you bet that's s Matt and I walk
away yeah you lazy man I appreciate it
thank you you shaving I appreciate you
coming to my shop that'll be about $50
[Music]
the NT you guys know that the fee
started in World War two when
african-american soldiers start wearing
their hair skin tight it resembled being
that good soldier in the seventh faith
we had the temple fade style haircut
with the coming back so these two fades
you got what up here that's actually
going to the side with the part that's
pretty smooth and on this one you have
the hair pull to the back and table get
that nice couple feet on the side this
cut bright hair has less in the nape and
you can show your magic as a barber you
can round it you can square it but it's
fine either way did you go number eight
we got the mohawk with the beard and
this popular and the barber shops all
around the world it's kind of like one
of my favorites but I want to freaking
philly-style one day I mean if you want
this popular style it's real easy to do
grow your hair out buzz the sides so in
the 9th photo we got the burst feed my
favorite birds fade it's the skin burst
for you when you start low above the air
then you just move up to a one to one
and a half to a two and make it pop the
first thing can be added to any men's
hair style short or long you can turn
into a frog pet the sides people it'll
be on top if you like the birds feet
check out the James heart and make me
look like
I'm gonna bring my boy Austin now we
won't hop right into this burst fee how
are you man very good thank you thanks a
lot
so you seem like a pretty cool guy
Austin what type of styles you rocking
these days I'm like a [ __ ] yeah the
brother look cool universal coolest ride
trying to get my beer like you man
hearing this cut right here and we'll go
with my engines to proceed from there
first up for you I got a date tomorrow
night brother this is right on time oh
you do yes indeed oh she's gonna say
Austin who cuts your hair
Austin what style do you only wear it in
the background square faded I usually do
square in the bag perfect this is
different from the high flattop because
it's messy do you think the racket is
better than this punch yes the racket is
about the sanitary reasons oh I believe
it's sponge or which bacteria yeah so
what you think man this is real clean
one of the cleanest lines I've ever had
appreciate you yeah thanks so much thank
you and enjoy your out of the will
[Music]
number 10 the feather fee its more
common in barber shops down these four
gentlemen and women and just want a
free-flowing feed and this one is pretty
nice this cut also is easy maintenance
so now we're going to talk about some
different hair textures some barbers are
hair stylist with me actually what is
your natural hair texture and number one
we got mo ver straight here then if you
want to drop all the way down to 4c we
got a more kinky texture today if you
want to go between 3a and 4a I'm a
purely texture as a professional barber
you supposed to have adjustable Clippers
so that your Clippers can move between
these different textures working with
different ethnic groups to get that
perfect style so the love of fade will
be the Elvis Presley I never did this
cut before but I really want to try it
so if anybody wanted they can come on
down to my shop so in this last but not
least picture I got the hot top favorite
my friend Brendan so Brendan what would
you like this faded like a skin fat I'll
get have skin Hoffy yeah yeah do you
know kitty play oh yeah yeah I get that
all the time so that's the look that
we're going here is not mid-nineties
this sir oh you got a nice canvas to
work okay I desperately need it to mass
right well over a month will you come to
the right place
hey so to achieve this style I want to
need my outliers so glue 0 on the side
so what I'm doing here you wants a
hopfield I've cut of my first guide
lines and make it a little short on the
bottom I want to show you how to knock
this guy lon it's cool got about the 50
mag with a one guard on there
so right down here I'm knocking out most
of the pork
now I'm going in to clean my god Lana
should take some adjustable Clippers
don't 0 turn them over y'all as far as
they do you see a lot of high tops
coming in these days yeah stuff like
that comes back yeah the hot top is
coming back ha ha they throw the low top
let me down are you like a low she
didn't come back
mad I'm rocking this right for 5 years
NASA us with my mentor can do this cut
15 minutes
no that's all you do
[Music]
all right Brandon you ready to see this
cut to the asylum
nobody yeah we'll get that line oh okay
so this is a hardtop feet typically war
bah kitten play and begat the king my
brother how you gonna beat that girl yes
[Music]